es ist eine ganz große frage wie sollen
wir mit ungeimpften umgehen das ist die
große frage die auch die deutsche
politik derzeit beschäftigt er mit einer
impfpflicht auf keinen fall haben uns
alle politiker monate lang versichert im
dezember dann los wende ja damals war
olaf scholz hierbei bild noch nicht ganz
kanzler aber da kündigte er die
impfpflicht bei uns an und
wir müssen dafür sorge tragen dass wir
auch einrichtungs bezogen eine
impfpflicht durchsetzen für die dortigen
beschäftigten der deutsche bundestag ist
da auf dem weg ich selber hat gesagt was
wir auch noch brauchen ist dass wir ein
gesetzgebungsverfahren auf den weg
bringen nur jeder abgeordnete nach
seinem gewissen abstimmt über eine
allgemeine impfpflicht mein vorschlag
ist dass wir nicht als regierung agieren
weil das eine gewissensfrage ist sondern
dass hier aus dem kreis der abgeordneten
heraus ein antrag im deutschen bundestag
eingebracht wird oder verschiedene
anträge die genau das regeln wann wir
eingebracht ich gehe davon aus dass es
noch dieses jahr losgeht denn meine idee
mein vorschlag ist ja dass der zeitpunkt
bis zu dem dann jeder und jede sich hat
impfen lassen auch nicht allzu fern
liegt also mein vorschlag anfang februar
oder anfang märz und das heißt es muss
auch jetzt bloß gehen
müsste bald losgehen anfangs februar
anfang märz die ins licht die wackelt
vorn haben wir exklusiv mit bayerns
ministerpräsident markus söder darüber
gesprochen und ob er daran glaubt dass
das ab märz nach möglichkeit sein wird
schauen sie mal hier ein
sehr schwer kann ich mir nicht
vorstellen dass das einzuhalten wäre
und ich mache mir halt auch ein bisschen
also ich bin ein bisserl sorge was die
gesamte glaubwürdigkeit der neuen
bundesregierung betrifft die alte
regierung hat auch viele fehler gemacht
und sie ist deswegen auch nicht mehr im
amt wahrscheinlich ist das auch einer
der gründe jetzt muss die neue regierung
bei dieser phase man spürt er richtig
dass auch da nicht umfragen das
vertrauen leicht zurückgeht das sage
jetzt nicht parteipolitisch sondern
staatspolitisch das ist nicht gut im
moment sondern gut wäre wenn man jetzt
klare schritte kommuniziert und sagt
wann und wo und warum und wenn das jetzt
so hin und her geht und keiner weiß
genau was und für wen und wann dieses
angesprochen haben es muss ja auch eine
struktur gefunden werden von der antwort
geführt werden dass auch dann sondern
wie die besetzung stattfinden soll wie
was bedeutet es für zukünftige
mutationen wie oft geht man davon aus
dass das stattfinden sollen alles in der
tat sich fragen und da glaube ich muss
die vorbereitung besser sein als dass
sich zehn abgeordnete zusammensetzen und
einen gruppenantrag formuliert das ist
regierungs kernbereich der exekutiven
und deswegen erwarten wir dass
schlichtweg einen vorschlag dazu ich
habe mich damit friedrich merz
abgestimmte erwarten einen vorschlag der
ampel dazu und nicht einen vorschlag von
56 abgeordneten also die impfpflicht
wackelt und jetzt sagt bayerns
ministerpräsident markus söder ganz
uneigennützig olaf scholz muss es regeln
der kanzler muss es regeln die
bundesregierung muss es regeln darüber
sprechen wir hier im studio mit dem chef
unseres parlaments büros mit reis schule
schönen guten tag ralf markus söder der
also das projekt impfpflicht dem olaf
scholz noch mal ganz deutlich vor die
füße hin kehrt du musst es regeln ist
das ein politisches manöver oder es
tatsächlich bundesregierung jetzt in der
pflicht wenn sie die impfpflicht will
kann auch richtig ist es keine
parteipolitik rein aus staatspolitischer
verantwortung wir wollen das noch mal
festhalten kein kleinliches gezänk
einfach nur das ist der 1000 das ist
ironie beiseite natürlich ist dort immer
parteipolitik mit am werke und söder hat
natürlich recht die regierung ist in der
pflicht ihre ankündigung vorzulegen und
nicht die opposition oder das parlament
und da hat er ändert hat einen wunden
punkt getroffen was wir hier gesehen
haben ist allerdings auch ein kleiner
schwenk von söder selbst der bisher auch
immer sehr stark für die impfpflicht
plädiert hat das hat er jetzt hier nicht
so ausgestellt denn in der tat ist die
regierung in der bringschuld ist
parteipolitisch völlig unklug ihr
irgendwie zuzuarbeiten oder so was sie
soll vorliegen und dann kann man sich
als opposition daran abarbeiten und das
andere problemen der sach problem da hat
er natürlich völlig recht die ampel
koalition hat im vergangenen jahr die
sektorale impfpflicht eingeführt für
bestimmte berufsgruppen die wird dann
ende märz wahrscheinlich in kraft treten
zu glauben dass eine allgemeine
impfpflicht vorher oder gar mit der
sektoralen
auf den weg zu bringen ist mit dem
gesamten parlamentarischen verfahren ist
sehr sehr schwierig und sachlich stehen
etliche probleme im raum die fdp ist
sehr sehr skeptisch es gibt sogar einen
antrag von wolfgang kubicki und anderen
abgeordneten gegen eine allgemeine
impfpflicht und man muss sich einfach
klarmachen es gibt kein deutsches imf
register und auch die fdp der
bundesjustizminister hat gesagt ist da
sehr skeptisch dass das aus dem boden zu
stampfen bedeutet wir wissen ja gar
nicht wer geimpft ist nation ganz genau
so ganz kann aber wir können in einer
autobahn können wir zwei autofahrer
anhalten und können prüfen ob sie einen
mit gestohlenes auto haben weil wir
natürlich einen kann auf einer bunten
sicher millionen relativ lange dauern
dann die die halter abfrage bei dem auto
funktioniert wenn ich einen menschen auf
der straße anhalte und seinen impfpass
sehen will kann ich nicht kontrollieren
ob er mir gerade eine fälschung vorliegt
oder nicht das ist sehr sehr schwierig
und das andere problem ist einfach wie
wollen wir denn eigentlich umsetzen die
österreicher haben einen bußgeldkatalog
eingerichtet 300 euro bis zu 3000 euro
wenn das nicht gezahlt wird wollen was
machen wie ein schwarzfahrer die wir
dann in beugehaft nehmen viel spaß dabei
also die bundesregierung ist da selbst
ackermann und da ist die opposition
überhaupt nicht geneigt ihr irgendwie zu
hilfe zu kommen das war eigentlich die
botschaft von markus söder als schuler
vielen herzlichen dank das große problem
ist ja auch wie oft muss noch gebucht
werden diese frage völlig offen im raum
und auch deshalb ist es gerade so schwer
einen weg zu finden wie man diese
impfpflicht überhaupt umsetzen möchte